and dude this guy next to me kept
putting a [ __ ] camera on my head okay
well no one ever picks you up because
what the [ __ ] no one knows
sometimes there was one time
where i i'm not trying to brag but like
my [ __ ] gets so crowded down there that
one time sounds like a bragga's club no
it's not a brag but one guy there was a
guy i was just sitting on a on a [ __ ]
i was waiting i was waiting on a plane
and i was i was waiting on a plate i was
in the [ __ ] terminal and i was
waiting delayed and dude this guy next
to me kept putting a [ __ ] camera on
my head and i'm like what are you doing
dude i finally the first time i was like
get out you know what the [ __ ] you know
and i just can't be i must be crazy why
would i put a camera on my head that's a
great question yeah and and he finally
kept putting the camera on my head and i
go hey buddy what are you doing and he
goes whoa he got scared and i was like
shocked he was so scared he said i'm
sorry i thought you were a tripod
um
and i said
oh
yeah you know
so he was like
i get it you're crowded downstairs and i
go and i was like oh so you didn't even
know i was human that's why i got scared
when i started talking he said yeah
because
it was at the same time you said yeah
because tripods don't talk oh okay i
don't believe you
that that happened guys try to put
cameras in my head all the [ __ ] time
just twisting it
twisting it
that is so stupid wow
[Laughter]
if a guy picks me up they instantly
think that guy's a cameraman
okay well no one ever picks you up
because
what the [ __ ] no one else hits you up
no one ever picks up an adult male human
um but yeah
okay what did he ask again oh yeah i
don't even know who the person was i got
so lost
[Music]